y combatir una epidemia de enfermedades
prevenibles es uno de los objetivos
principales de la nueva guía sobre la
reducción del sodio de la administración
de alimentos y medicamentos
estadounidense efe de hoy la feria está
emitiendo una guía final para la
industria alimentaria que proporciona
objetivos voluntarios de reducción de
sodio a corto plazo 2.5 años para una
amplia gama de alimentos procesados
envasados y preparados con el objetivo
de reducir la cantidad de sodio en el
suministro de alimentos en eeuu la feria
también anotó que a diario los
estadounidenses consumen un promedio de
50% más de sodio del límite recomendado
para los mayores de 14 años y que el 95%
de los niños de 2 a 13 años superan los
límites recomendados de sodio para sus
grupos de edad la agencia busca
disminuir la ingesta de sodio a 3000
miligramos por día con respecto a los 3
mil 400 miligramos actuales es decir una
reducción del 12% en los peligros del
sodio son demasiados en realidad sabemos
que afecta el riñón
o acz así que va a afectar nuestra
presión arterial y tenemos una explosión
de presión arterial alta
se estima que 4 de cada 10
estadounidenses adultos sufren de
presión arterial alta principal causa de
ataques cardíacos y cerebrales por lo
que la determinación ha sido bien
recibida me encanta si miras los
alimentos cuando estás en el
supermercado y yo los invito a menudo la
mayoría de los alimentos envasados
tienen un alto contenido en sodio la
decisión podría afectar a la industria
de alimentos envasados y de la comida
rápida la asociación estadounidense del
corazón máximo referente local en
cardiología asegura que las
recomendaciones de la rda siguen
quedándose cortas